the worst I went and saw a mall Santa
Brian you know how anti mall said I am I
went Bob not by choice my girl signed me
and I get up for it when you have kids
you're standing that line to meet mall
Santa and that's appalling yes their
lines there instead like they went to
the Grove obviously had an appointment
but when we get there this is what
bothered me tight you know Tiger loves
everyone is his loving kids so he hugs
them Santa's like oh good boys like rub
his back I'm like EEZ Santa easy and
then he goes oh he kept calling him
sweetie and then I was a cake boy though
huh so sweetie doesn't work you know if
they call it it rubbed me the wrong way
you've got off sweeties yeah that's a
guy that's so much he said oh this is so
interesti seconds I had a guy call my
son sweetheart and he kept call him
sweetheart and it was like you know I
mean they're so cute and they're so
little at that age but my friend's
father I said oh I was in college and I
and I said I was I never forgot this I
said you know I drove faster so I get
there and he said honey listen don't
ever speed like that on and I'll tell
you why he called me honey twice he just
cared about me they didn't want me to
speaks didn't want me to die but his
older man but he's like honey you don't
have to swing I was and I was like I'm
um I'm 1920 you just can't call me
[ __ ] look like when I get my
Starbucks when this lady sometimes in
the morn when I go there she goes
anything else sweetie I'm like well I'm
older than you so don't call me sweetie
though yeah I thought I don't mind that
I don't mind if it's a it's a gals but
they're really young I feel like like
she's like she looks like kids Jukes
younger that can but white yeah and
she's like sweetie and like I had a cow
call me Dollface she goes all right doll
face is that all who's gonna like this
hey man I'm not a doll face it's was
like I big dummy anything else like well
no man my wedding my buddy Jimmy Burke
likes to do that [ __ ] to me I'll be will
be at dinner and I'll be like a waiter
or we'll be around some guys and he'll
he'll [ __ ] him put his arm
he'll just put his arm gently around the
small my waist already a problem and he
goes sweetheart you want a drink
sweet okay you want a drink bad like
that I'm like dude don't start with that
[ __ ]
honey chaos what's up honey what's going
on he keeps his arm there and I go get
your [ __ ] on out of here you got
these guys over here get your arm off me
there's also the duty calls your girl or
any girl babe yeah baby anything like
well it's not your baby doll is it not
your babe bro that your baby is a girl
so let's not call her babe
Hey Baby you want some dude like mmm not
comfortable yeah that's a little weird
you're the mall saying that strange dude
yeah I just don't trust a man I just
don't get that vibe mall Santa they
don't keep that bud
sweetie he's so cute I would call me
he's cute as [ __ ] when you're a little
like that doesn't matter but yeah super
cute and I [ __ ] up
don't don't speed honey you know why
that's funny it's you're not gonna get
there any faster see if I see right now
if you buy a Viper online I wonder what
you you have to go through you have to
have a certain license to buy a
poisonous snake do you yeah you can't
buy a poisonous snake without lifting
the thing and you can't you don't do
Fang snakes you do certain ones versus
you have to see you can take out there
you take I can take out there yeah but
uh oh [ __ ] him to Jake the snake that
you know his snakes they took the venom
they took the gland the venomous glands
out of his pythons where the [ __ ] they
were they they defend it but they'd
still [ __ ] you up you saying you get bit
by any of these I'll do it I'll take
that [ __ ] hand sauce kill
Palestinians kill Viper somebody we knew
inside Arabia got bit by one of those
they're cool die badly
Jesus Christ dude baby West African
rhino 150 bucks do you we're dolls for
Christmas you don't wanna know the word
no honest you don't want to be bitten by
any of those now the real badass is that
gaboon viper dude I can buy a desert
horned Viper for 300 bucks yeah you can
click on that and the Gumpert they do
overnight [ __ ] a gaboon viper dude will
bite you do the green bush Viper look
cheap I thought they'd be like in the
thousands yeah I know I was trying to
buy a a lot of eggs through amazing
Vipers almost seamless blending into the
sand all right
silent precise is highly venomous and
I'll please check your local laws before
purchasing
whatever add-to-cart chin I'll take a
mail what about you
I mean shouldn't do this Add to Cart
all right man how do we do it hold on to
rate holds much out of the cart we can
buy it right now 125 so you don't have a
coupon yeah you got it it's at least 125
bucks for shipping wha a desert horn
vibe - yeah things came along that's not
a plane snakes on a plane bro dude look
at that so it's basically four hundred
fifty bucks to get this thing to us to
get a lake that was kill you and you
could you if you wanted to assassinate
somebody I guess what would you do put
it in their mailbox you wanted to kill
feel we could just put that thing in the
studio you know you put it if you put
that in somebody's mailbox there was a
guy who tried to kill somebody that way
with a rattlesnake put it in the guy's
mailbox Jesus Christ to rattle but if
you put a [ __ ] desert horned Viper
and somebody's Chino back can i buy king
cobra dude if I can buy king cobra Oh
Ginuwine king cobra christmas i will buy
it with my American Express right now on
this podcast would you would you take
care of it for us Jen no no I don't
think so dude think how many [ __ ]
dude you would get but if you had a
[ __ ] king cobra in your apartment
nothing's gonna help you could make
money you could pay people hey come
check out my Cobra $5.00 Tim in my
apartment check out my Cobra five years
boy you boys are for watching remember
we watched the fights we watched the
canal fight which we can get though
watch the we watch the I mean the three
rounds quite a fight yeah we fight what
else
they were like let it go well the whole
point of that fight I think was to get
us to download that app I had problems
that can undo a task the [ __ ] all Rayna
that turns in the zone well their app
itself is Ray died although the app
itself called does his own da Zn is that
one you add this sound it's you guys
it's the black thing right
you don't pay for I know I had it down
no I got it for free on Apple TV
oh you know I know it's just like that
one that one whatever that is that's
dessert is ready operator
I'd say what's your fee pay-per-views oh
there it is ready for my stream
illegally stream and all defense
including UFC so it's fine I see how you
make that up no I have my smart TV I'm
sure you'll note that app with Frank
took us forever and then we watched it
hot but real quick how difficult is it
to get the design [ __ ] going it took us
I'd say an hour to get it I was 45
minutes in I want you up [ __ ] Frank
Frank it Mikey Franco gon [ __ ] cuz I
could happen to put my name my email my
password I'm gonna password ask for five
characters I know did you see that what
[ __ ] bass board needs five K you know
what a character is dollar sign so I was
like I don't remember what the character
I was like I don't know I put in five
hours out and I turn around every
waiting for me you done with you know
what this man is fighting me over in
five rounds is always super how did you
know that champion he's taller so
totally should've so one time on
Seinfeld I guess there was an episode
about eating the muffin top just the top
of the muffin that's what I do
and what's his name Kevin James had a
whole bit on how you just even know
muffin yeah and it was obvious that
there was a guy was probably a writer
who saw him who sit in the back of the
room and went and that's fine
but and he never sued him stuff but that
would 100% and easily be something that
you know if you could prove it but you
couldn't but there are certain things
where you can make some money yeah
and I'm not a sue guy I've never I never
been in a lawsuit owner you know what
would you guys do if like say you guys
are both doing your special and there's
like a really big joke in there that you
guys did and then some of you someone
just jacked it why don't you sue those
guys I just write another one no I'd
never sue somebody for that I've had
that happen to me a couple of times all
right that's gonna happen in a big-name
comic that you guys know tell a friend
of ours yeah oh sure
mm-hmm that's gonna happen here soon I'm
not as loosey-goosey with them Brian I
think you're saying like like a good
like a good chunk of whatever and they
released it before is [ __ ] up no
they're not the you time but then you're
just a bad person you can worsen you
just a piece of [ __ ] I wouldn't back out
all good Mouse right new one like no
hell no yeah might come after you
yeah I think is that's a different
animal Dave does people get found out on
the internet now you can't get away with
that [ __ ] at all you'll get found out
they put it together and you're like oh
[ __ ] Seinfeld rider wants McDonald's to
pay up for the muffin top idea what this
is a lot time with those TV show yeah
there's so many riders you know that was
Amy Schumer's defense you so many riders
I didn't know they were stealing from me
yeah that's fair you don't because you
have a lot of riders you never forget we
had a bit I thought was when they're
kids we had doing this big wooden TVs
and I'd like the cloth speakers on the
side and we would always watch movies
and we'd always watch it every Friday
night we'd watch like Robocop or some
[ __ ] like that or bloodsport and we're
all we did BJ of me and my dad be in the
middle we'd sit down this we like this
big like Paulo that with all three of us
could fit on and they were sitting there
and it smelled like pure [ __ ] I mean
this felt horrible my dad does not play
you know my daddy goes who farted and I
look at Jay I'm like I definitely did it
my dad's like who the [ __ ] farted and
when I'm like I have no idea it smells I
mean it shows off all and my that's like
seriously guys who farted and he's like
getting mad and Jaycee I swear to god it
wasn't me I was like dad it wasn't me I
mean I was like well someone did it like
you know upset stops the movie like who
farted like that and because it was like
he was [ __ ] destroying the house are
you so bad and then but it goes well
something's up like it starts walking
around and we had this cat dad let it go
I know for sure relax if someone did
relax but neither one was dead we had
this cat we called it mama cat kind of
super creative she was the mom of the
other cats this cat called mama cat
lives a tabby
decided you don't want I don't like it
here took a [ __ ] behind the TV the size
of a fist
but yeah so man oh dude and he goes
unbelievable man [ __ ] hate these cats
I'm not lying I never saw it Kent then
from there on out I don't know what he
did with it I don't know what happened
to it
[ __ ] college I come home with his
girl I liked so much it was so hot
and I was I couldn't least she's coming
back to my place so of course I'm just
like I forget everything we go at it we
start going at it and we are just in the
act
I'm I'm having a sexy me I'm having sex
on the couch smoke show him no
protection on that I hide this no I got
snow I go oh no and she goes something's
going on and I look over and my pitbull
his I didn't walk him cuz I I was so
excited
my dog cuz I can't hold it he's
squatting and [ __ ] a giant head
right on my for not to viewing shop sir
McDonald thousand oh I gotta clean this
out the whole lot it was the biggest
[ __ ] time today I mean just weekend it
just didn't go well I don't remember
yeah I cleaned it up and did this this
[ __ ] weekend I went like was
something stunk in my house I'm cleaning
my house up and something stunk I kept
looking on the table with a [ __ ] who
shat is the dog farting it was the plant
plants the water and the plants in there
a long time and the man that can smell
like [ __ ] rut Oh rocks it's nasty when
that when the plant matter starts to
decompose it was the worse when you see
my back rippling I pull myself up like a
champ like a champ thirty times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift